[Music]
hey guys a few days ago we received the
first official game insurance season a
teaser this teaser includes a detailed
description of the opening scene the
largest battle scene ever filmed for not
only game internals but for the
television in general and the mysterious
scene from the very finale I did
breakdown of all of this I haven't seen
it already make sure to do so anyways
let's take a look at a scene from the
finale that might be confirming some of
my most popular theories Sameach Ned
Stark corrugator garyun could be alive
and excludes a report and description of
this mysterious scene from the series
finale says what's being filmed here is
episode 6 the series finale like
Harrington going into the table read I
don't know anything about the final
season storyline I look around at the
meticulously constructed said that I've
never seen on the show before several
actors are performing and I'm stunned
they're characters in the finale that I
did not expect I gradually begin to
piece together what has happened in
Westeros or the previous five episodes
and try not to look like I'm freaking
out it's noted that their characters and
last episodes of Game of Thrones that he
did not expect now as all is said in a
previous video we don't know if this
means there are characters we do not
expect in terms of them surviving along
or if this means that there are some
unexpected characters reappearing in the
very last episode it could very well
just be one of the main characters
surviving more than we expected but what
I really leave the reporters stunned
he's done he's freaking out about this
character appearing in a series finale
meaning it's probably character no one
expects coming back in the series ever
again additionally I think it's probably
character who we think is that
reappearing and leaving us in shock with
that being said let's take a look at who
might be this character whose presence
in the Game of Thrones finale we leave a
stand and make us freaked out as my most
popular theory states it could be that
fans favorite character Ned Stark is not
dead but is rather alive and will
finally reappear I've never really been
into those theories in which someone is
so dying is actually alive but upon
watching the show and upon rereading the
books I came up to this theory and as
much as this theory has been accepted
among the fandom and shared by all the
most popular mainstream media it's also
been rejected by many however none can
claim that this theory doesn't sound
somewhat convincing after hearing out
all the hints and clues ok let's take a
look at the theory as well as that all
the clues and hints we have about a
possibility of the most honorable man in
some kingdoms Eddard Stark being alive
and reappearing in a series finale in
this theory amanda was beheaded by Suri
limb pain on the steps of the great Sept
of Baelor was not actually net himself
but was jockey Hagar wearing the Nets
face okay as we all know error that
on trying to carry out the justice and
Robert's will was betrayed by Slynt and
Baelish whereupon he was imprisoned in
the black cells beneath the red keep at
the same time a mysterious man
introducing himself as a heretic
criminal who later found out is a
faceless man assassin was also arrested
and put in the dungeons
so why did Jackie got himself arrested
to save Ned's life perhaps we know for a
fact that Jackie and clearly got himself
arrested on purpose since the faith's
Manassas and most certainly could not
have ever been arrested against his will
according to this theory Jackie Hegar
was highly paid for his services which
in this case will be helping Ned start
to avoid the death and no it's not much
you're probably thinking right now
Jackie did not switch his face with net
he switched it with Syrio Forel you
might be confused at this point by the
promise you understand everything once
we're done as we all know Syrio Forel is
a master swordfighter from the free city
of Braavos
hired by Ned Stark to train his daughter
Aria upon discovering that his daughter
owns a sword upon his Restless regard
let Bester marry trent of the Kingsguard
came for her to take her into custody
which ended its very engaging Sumerian
with his wooden sword by this theory
Syria did not die as you're still far
better with his wooden sword than a
dozen Lannister guards along with sir
Meryn Trant
which is a fact and according to this
theory serum managed to defeat him and
the evidence supporting this part of a
theory would be the sea in which the
Hound left so hard on her statement that
she learned how to fight from the first
order brows who was apparently killed by
Sir Marian who's one of the worst
fighters and members of the Kingsguard
probably in its history the greatest
swordsman who ever lived
Syrio Forel the first sword to the
Sealord of Braavos he was killed by
Meryn Trant rod the greatest swordsman
who ever lived killed by Meryn
so this point of the theory Ned Stark in
jocking ruined ourselves which matches
the game eternal series while in this
theory also did not die and was still in
King's Landing
he then decided to help in stark by this
theory Jackie Hegar was arrested on
purpose which is most likely true since
I can imagine that a faceless man could
have been arrested against as well
jogging out himself arrested because of
Ned Stark in order to get himself in the
dungeons for Ned is and in order to help
him in order to sacrifice his life for
Nance
it's said that for a good price a cult
of religiousness
since that worship the many-faced God
will grant the gift of death to anyone
in the world but tilde for a good price
offer their own life to the many-faced
God jacking by this theory there is also
questionable according to this theory
Jackie hug our faceless men created a
face that looked just like Ned's
and wore it on the day of Ned's
beheading which would mean that instead
of Ned yo Jackie who died was beheaded
in the front steps of the great Sept of
Baelor faceless men kill people take
their faces and wear them when it's
necessary to disguise themselves or to
accomplish a task but are they able to
create faces from other faces as some
kind of proved that it's possible for
the faceless man to shape faces to make
it look just like they wanted to I'm
relying gonna see that took place in the
season 5 finale a cinema Jackie hugger
or arias faithful are yourself was
standing just beside the scene might be
confirming that the faceless men
assassins can never face a person that
is not dead of a person that is still
alive since they might be able to create
a mask from other faces that could look
just like the face of the person they
want to portray if you're wondering what
was serious role it's actually pretty
simple
both the jock in and Ned were arrested
then were in their cells which means
that while Jackie Kagari plays his face
with a face almost identical to Ned
Stark's someone had to release net free
that someone also had to replace jock in
and take Jackie's face so this point
Jackie who plays his lorry at the
criminal face with Ned's face that he
created himself well in stark was
released free from his cell with the
help of Syrio Forel which was not that
hard not to mention impossible since
fairs also could have done the same if
you wanted to
so Jackie knees beheaded Ned Stark is
set free and Sarah took Jackie's former
face of the Loretto criminal and
continued to per chain he was recruited
by urine and his the one who helped re
multiple times Syria wearing jackets
face might have been hinted by the scene
which one's the many-faced God I see the
stranger
I see the drowned God I see the way
would face there is only one God a girl
knows his name
there's only one God then you know his
name said Jack into Arya which might be
a confirmation that Syria took face of a
faceless man that died for Ned took a
face of jogging Hegar how so you might
wonder if you not be paying close
attention while watching the show well
it will explain how Jackie knew that Ari
already knows God's name which she in
fact noon because Siri already told her
during their training a few seasons
earlier Syria said to her there's only
one God and His name is death do you
pray to the gods
there is only one God and His name is
death isn't it interesting how Jackie
knows that Siri already told her the
name of one true God if the Syriac I'm
showing the final season it would also
explain why jacking was so protected
towards Aria and why he taught her to
become a skilled fighter it would also
explain how Jackie knew that re already
knows the name of one true God and most
importantly why Jackie Hegar was smiling
when arias said to him a girl is arya
stark from Winterfell and I'm going home
it's because Jacquin was Syrio Forel all
along upon rereading the books I've also
found some kind of a hidden hints in
there they're going favor to this theory
with Jack in war Ned's face and was
beheaded the first skint would be
senseless claiming that her father's
head looked really unlike her father the
second hint would be Caitlyn statement
that Ned's bones don't look like Ned's
but rather likes someone smaller than
that and the last third hint would be a
statement that Ned an execution day
looked different which he thinks was the
result of Ned's injury that he got from
his confrontation with Jamie but let's
face it I wounded leg doesn't change
your facial features one final clue
could be the last words from Ned Stark
just a moment before he was beheaded
that mattered a few words to himself and
as I keep rewatching and rewatching it a
more and more Stern that he says all men
must die Valar morghulis
as much as Ned Stark sing a greeting in
high Valyrian language that is common in
Braavos sounds ridiculous maybe hear a
hint that Ned Stark is actually alive
because if naturally said Valar
morghulis before his beheading it might
be some kind of approved that is doing
favor to my theory that I brought you
over a year ago it was shocking who
matter to himself all men must die by
lame Agulhas while wearing Nets face
let's take a look at the final clue that
came with a reunion between the stark
sisters maybe this scene is supposed to
be a connection between the books and
the show since in the books arias says
that her father an execution they look
different and now in the show she says
his statue looks nothing like him is
this supposed to foreshadow Ned's come
back that would definitely leave a stand
and make us all freak out isn't it
structurally going to fulfill the last
promise he's ever given him being the
one to reveal John the truth about his
parents
perhaps it's Rhaegar Targaryen who we
don't expect to see ever again
reappearing in a series finale alive and
well in this theory Rhaegar Targaryen
the son of the Mad King the brother of
Dany and the father of John Snow
basically one of the most important
characters in the game appearance is not
that but is rather live
one of the faceless men on Bravo's when
you look at it rhaegar targaryen and
jacking her car have a lot of
similarities fans mostly point out of
the fact that both of them shared the
same grace and have a same long baby
hair if jackeen does indeed turn out to
be regard the Silver Streak in his hair
would not be the only indication as
there are many more clothes in both the
books and the show series let's start
from the very beginning from Rhaegar's
alleged death the source says Prince
Rhaegar met Lord Robert Baratheon in
combat at the fort during the Battle of
the Trident but the pair had a legendary
duel in the raging rivers of the trident
Rhaegar despite warning Robert was
struck down with a massive blow from
Robert's war hammer which scattered the
rubies encrusted in Rhaegar's Armour
under the water it said that the rubies
full like drops of blood from the chest
of a dying Prince and he sank to his
knees in the water and with his last
breath murmured the woman's name well
Rhaegar was lying dead in the stream
soldiers of both armies scrambled in the
water to search for true rubies
thereafter the location was named the
Ruby fort let's firstly point out the
obvious it specifically highlighted at
Rhaegar war his iconic Knight black
plate armor with the three-headed dragon
of House Targaryen decorated in rubies
on his breastplate edition before they
which this battle took place his name
for the rubies that were knocked from
prince rhaegar breastplate now why is it
so important for george RR martin as
well as for the showrunners to make it
very clear that Rhaegar wore his iconic
armor that had rubies attached to it
why so much focused on reyga's rubies
why is it such a big plot point and
subject brought up whenever the Battle
of the Trident Touareg are brought up in
these theories for sharing this Robert
did not fight Rhaegar but rather someone
else with glamoured himself in the form
of Rhaegar using rubies as it was
confirmed in 60s and rubies can be used
to glamour its owners into a form or
person they want to be known sanjay uses
a to hide the true form of an extremely
old woman in the books Mance Rayder also
glamour to appear as Rattleshirt via the
Reuben his risk of the power in rubies
is something called glamour where you
can basically use them with the power of
the Lord of Light to project a different
image of yourself
email Sanjaya mens can use that it's
most certainly not out of the realm of
possibilities that someone his glamour
himself in the form of Rhaegar using
these same rubies and sacrificed his
life for the beloved prince after the
fall of House Targaryen in the world
believing him that in this theory
Rhaegar went to Braavos and the house of
black and white to become a faceless man
just as Arya Stark did when her house
fell and when everyone thought she was
dead if Rhaegar in fact is not
wearing a face of jocking kagari it
would be very strange for a faceless man
to allow himself being captured and
thrown in the black cells without a good
reason
that reason could be to save Ned Stark
and take his place on the execution day
but helping Ned's daughter would also be
a good reason if Jackie is not some
random faceless man paid for his
services but rather Egger himself a
virtual is wrecker then he had a very
good reason to be captured which is
returning a favor to Ned Stark of
protecting his child just like Ned
protected his it's definitely not out of
the realm of possibilities that Rhaegar
came back to King's Landing as Jackie in
to try and help protect the child of a
man who is the sole reason his son John
is alive and well it's also quite
interesting how it seems like Jackie
solely in an area from the very start in
one of their conversations Jack in says
to Arya a girl has more courage than
sense the sentence was also accompanied
with a smiling face everyone who knew
lianna claims that arias just like her
not only by Luke but also by courage and
mildness Sagar not only helps Arya who
looks and behaves just like currently
and then returning a favor of protecting
his child to Ned but he also later
trained her to become someone she just
like currently and I always wanted to be
a fighter it's also important to
highlight it if Jackie is some random
faceless man assassin he would not be
happy and proud of Arya when she reclaim
her stark name and rejected to be no one
neither would he lie were to leave so
Jackie needs a de rigueur Targaryen or
Syrio Forel as the previous theory
states in conclusion the unexpected
character playing a role in Game of
Thrones finale that will leave a stand
that make us freak out could potentially
be Ned Stark or Rhaegar Targaryen let me
know your opinion about his theories
some curious who do you think could be
this mysterious character and as always
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see in the
next time peace
[Music]